ATR-42
R72 are two brothers which made up a family of twin engine turboprop airliners developed
by the French-Italian ATR Joint Venture in the early 1980s.
The story of these planes is long and full of adventures.
Everything starts a bit similar to the de Havilland Canada story in the early 1970s.
These times were rather unclear for the field of turboprop airliners.
Jet engine technology was developing at a tremendous pace.
十何亿航班线潜众比险更多予美轿,
而年载型年载型航班线潜众比较过于其他原型的居民。
载型的载型航班线潜众比较高速运动工厨。
载型航班线潜众比较高速运动工厨,
且很快乐流行作统贷入。
手剪达机航班线潜众比较高速运动工程式较为了普通的旧年轻型的故事,
而是非常失敗,
但企業不見得不太太的財頭
並不是特別的急
在建議中的改變
有些人的問題
不少了
1973年代的油 crisis
和暫度的營業減少
被迫在市場的市場
较大量的重量量
以前是否正確的
是否則是否則了
現在是個大量的問題
長期的延長
長期的大量量
也還要更多的
但航空間
在一般的游航中,也許多人在一般的游航中,也許多人在一般的游航中,
而且並且在一般人的游航中,並且不可能是用於這類型的游航中,
它是很可能的玩具在一般的游航中,
一開始的游航中,是一種游航中的游航中,
一種游航中,但四種游航中,一種游航中,
一種游航中,並且不足以外的游航中,
但另一種游航中,也許有需要的需要有空間的游航中,
De Havilland Canada had begun to create a new, more suitable aircraft, the future Dash 8.
Seeing the potential success of this plane, European aircraft manufacturers also got to work.
Their aircraft were developed in the Netherlands, Sweden, France and Italy.
Moreover, projects of the French and the Italians turned out to be the most complex and promising,
which on one hand would enable them to conquer the market in the future,
而另一方面,加上了失去失去失去失去的資源。
Aviation不是不一家 business。
同時,在同時,
the European aviation industry went through a stormy period of reorganization,
with mergers of previously local manufacturers.
The most bright example of this process was, of course,
the birth of Airbus industry
and the creation of the breakthrough A300 airliner in 1972.
Remaining in the trend of European cooperation,The French Aerospatiale, now part of the Airbus Corporation, and the Italian Aereitalia, now part of the Leonardo Corporation, decided to work together
on a new turboprop aircraft, sharing all available technologies as well as the risks.
In 1981 a joint venture agreement was signed.
The company received the name ATR, which in French means Avion de Transpôle Regional,
英语的英语,Aerii da Transporto Regionale。
英语,它是什么是,Regional Air Transport,
长 and boring.
优优独播,他们不得找到美容,像 Concorde,
在两语言中。
新的公司,它设计是总是由整个整体的生活。
从设计,到设计和设计。
工作的练习续续维持续续。
以军的设计,1984年,第一航空缘,
加快的公司,也在演出的海報。
法國安裝的海報,法國安裝。
海報,有所指的研究,達成的海報。
是1985年級。
當初,一種研究,當船會改變了很多改變。
而而成品的研究開放了一種改變成的海報,
於是蒂加加快速的。
新鮮的工程開始開始開始於1週 1985。
ATR42-300 received 1800hp Pratt Whitney PW120 turboprop engines.
With a maximum takeoff weight of 37300lbs , it could carry 48 passengers at a distance
of up to 459nm or 850km.
Not too far away, but for Europe it is quite enough.
The cabin had a layout of 2 plus 2 and for its role was quite classic.
All the analogues were give or take the same.
The plane was very successful.
Already by 1986, the number of orders reached a sufficient volume in order for ATR to decide
to expand the model line and increase production rates.
A big step was the creation of another full-fledged modification, the ATR-72.
The aircraft with a stretched fuselage accommodated 72-74 passengers, which expanded the potential
market for the model.
The decision was right.
At the moment, 70% of all ATRs are of the model 72.
The first flight of the aircraft was performed in 1988.
In parallel with this, the European manufacturer continued to expand the geography of deliveries,
and in the same 1988 entered the North American market, receiving orders for several dozen
從 Texas Air Corporation和 Transworld Express
已經在1989,ATR也有約400公司,
在那時候,200公司已在了兩種公司
在那時候,200公司已在出現了
ATR的產品是在 Italy和France,
在唯一期中央是在船延長的工具
在唯一夾部的工具,
The wings are made at the Airbus factory in Bordeaux.
The final assembly center, test base and supply center,as well as the ATR headquarter, are located in Toulouse.The ATR42 and ATR72 models are being unified and produced on one line, which allows to
significantly optimize the work and maintain the supply of both models.
In many regards to this solution, the ATR42 is in fact the only turboprop aircraft with
the capacity of less than 50 seats, which manages to be produced until now.
1980s and 90s, during a period of low fuel prices, the turboprop aircraft market decreased
while the competition increased.
To maintain efficiency, in competition with its peers, the ATR42 continued to be upgraded.
The 42-300 and 42-320 models differed in engine versions and were produced until the mid-1990s.
一步進行的發展是一步的造型的ATR42-500
它們的第一次飛機是1994
而且收入新的機器,運動和運動機器
提供的重量也增加到18.6吋
或40100磅
老年代的航空也有新的航空
新的72-100系列是新的72-200
加上新的機器,更新的機器
mostly similar to the 42-500 model.
Unification was a great advantage of the family and was followed strictly.
A feature of the ATR family was the rejection of the auxiliary power unit.
Yes, the APU is very useful on the ground and allows to work with engines turned off,
but they are not needed in flight and you still have to carry them.
On large planes it is necessary, okay, but on small ones the decision is already not so clear.
ATR still installs the APU, but in the basic configuration they offer other solutions.
Firstly, the ground infrastructure is used to power the aircraft, or it can use the generator
from the engine, that is, on the little Model 42.
The Model ATR72, equipped with more powerful and voracious engines, has a special economical
system.
In engine number two, it is possible to start the turbine on a minimal mode, only for the
電源 without propeller rotation. This is called the hotel mode.
The serious production of the aircraft continued quite actively, although low fuel prices reduced
demand. In the beginning of the 2000s, ATR delivered their 600s aircraft to customers,
and the mark of 700 aircraft was overcome only in 2006.
Despite the fact that a number of competing models were actively leaving the market,
The pressure of a new generation of regional jets affected demand.
The Embraer E-Jet, as we know, was very popular.
In 2007,ATR announced the creation of a new generation of its aircraft, exactly when Bombardier
announced the Q400X program.
A large-scale upgrade of the family was supposed to lead to the creation of the ATR42-600 and
ATR72-600 models, more efficient, comfortable and easy to use.
The aircraft received upgraded PW-127M engines with 2160殊的 同时,加速1回合并且能力量量量的继续游 多。
同时,可能会否加了个绘度伤游家。
这些东西也可以同时,到这篇过程中。
起来的这个新加密总统 6-blade propellers,
和那个火灭更能更完整!
这插机也挺有机。
新 cabin,新 glass cockpit, avionics, etc.
In addition, a few years after,
a next local modernization of the cabin gave the ATR-72 increased capacity
from 74 to 78 passengers.
The earlier modest flight range was brought to the more relevant for our time.
The 42nd is now flying at a distance of up to 700 miles or 1300 kilometers
and the older brother up to 800 miles or 1500 kilometers.
The ATR-72-600 prototype took off in July 2009.
The younger brother left the ground in March 2010.
The ATR airplanes are some of the most successful in the class at the moment and are distinguished
by high reliability.
However, their history could not avoid accidents.
During the period of operation, up until 2018, the ATR-42 and 72 aircraft were participants
在63事件中的事件和事件,
在全身的死亡,
在674人的死亡。
是的,船船不得了保持安全 records,
但必須要注意,
这些是在35年生的船船
和1,50000船船。
船船是企业的可能性的改造,
by creating cargo, special and patrol versions. Considering the drop in demand for ATR-42,
they are looking for the possibility of creating the version with a shortened takeoff and landing,
which will allow the aircraft to work on runways up to 800 meters long. On the basis of the model
ATR-72, the possibility of creating the version with an extended fuselage and the capacity of up
90 passengers is being considered. Deliveries were also helped by a new wave of rising fuel prices.
Cost-efficient and reasonably effective turboprop aircraft are in steady demand, especially in the
countries that do not have a developed airfield infrastructure. ATR occupies almost half of the
regional aircraft market with a capacity of 50 to 90 passengers, in fact sharing it with Bombardier.
他們 managed to cut the market pie pretty well, while not getting into frontal competition
with new generation jet airliners, which are slowly moving towards increased capacity and
range.
Aircraft production continues, and ATR remains one of the leaders of this modest but important
niche.
And that's all.
Subscribe to the channel and don't forget to like the video.
Fast flights and soft landings to you.
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜